[Music]
foreign
[Music]
episode of what Huggy Rao and I decided
to call this [ __ ] fixers
um we're this is roughly a monthly
series
um where we talk to people who are good
at getting in and fixing organizational
problems and our first guest is my
friend uh David Kelly and David who for
many of you needs no introduction
um David is a Stanford Professor he's a
chaired professor the thing I love about
David is he's beat the system completely
has no PhD he doesn't do Publications
but he has done things like started a
company that that created thousands of
products and other changes Ideo
um he's really the driving force behind
the Stanford d-school sort of the
Innovation education shop at Stanford
and uh so David is somebody who has
always to me pushed institutions to the
point where I I never thought things
were possible and then that kind of
change occurred and you you you come up
with stuff that I still can't believe
that you've gotten away with to tell you
the truth and the so the first time I
met David I looked it up
1993. we well so we've known each other
a long time and and my students kept
doing case studies of this crazy guy
with a mustache named David Kelly and so
one of my PhD students at I one of your
former students Andy hargadon and I we
went to see David in Downtown Palo Alto
I still remember he was in the sauce
with all this junk in it all this
products and everything and we said
David we want to do an ethnography and
and he gave us the phone list of idea
when I do had about 45 employees in
Downtown Palo Alto in those days and you
said here's the phone list stay as long
as you want and we stayed a year and a
half and then I was an ideal fellow for
20 or so and you still haven't gotten
rid of it so Stephen let's let's start
out and talk about about Ideo because uh
you and uh and Bill mogridge and
somebody else started idea what was the
con concept behind that because at that
time it was a very radical design firm
Excuse me yes the real truth is that
idea started in 1978 wow as a company of
the Kelly designed and then it became
David Kelly designed a very humble title
[Music]
and yes dkd and um uh audio happened
later that with the merger of some other
companies but it's it's the same entity
the whole time anyway the um I had the
whole impetus for this was I had worked
in Corporate America for a while and I
really hated it it was really bad for me
um you know they they took you and sat
you down next to somebody and say this
is the person on your team you know and
um then the project came from somewhere
and it it was already the project
already like something this big to work
on yeah yeah you know you know and the
and the project already had the solution
embedded in the project statement so
what I really wanted to do with the with
the beginning of Ideo was to um
to make it such that projects allowed
the people who were working on them to
come up with new to the world stuff
rather than having it already well
defined and maybe most importantly uh I
wanted people to have choice in who they
worked with yep um and so
um I would pick my friends they would
pick other people that they knew that
they liked and so we from the center we
built out this team based on uh who we
wanted to work with it's a completely
different environment when you're
basically treating the other person as a
friend as opposed to as as a colleague I
don't know quite how to describe that
but that's what happened that was the
magic of the early days was you know
when we needed to do something it's like
how would friends answer that question
yeah that's how they decided so I
remember I mean when I first got there
and met you I was just sort of astounded
because I was worth because you were a
consulting firm I was used to other
firms and you said to me it some client
came with an inquiry and you said to him
well let's see if anybody here is
interested in working on it yeah and if
they're if they're interested that'll be
great but if they're not interested then
we won't be able to do it for you it
just sort of blew my mind because like I
was just a you know corporate in America
you will do this I mean that was the
whole model yeah yeah sure we had an
early
um sales guy named Dave David Haygood
and um he he would tell uh potential
clients they say they had this project
and he would say you know that project's
not interesting enough for me to take it
back to the company you know and and
then companies would try to make their
project more interesting it's kind of
arrogant but it wouldn't work in our in
our culture to be forced to work on
something and we were constantly
um rejecting things you know some people
wouldn't work for the military so we
didn't do anything for the military some
people thought you know selling
carbonated beverages to Children you
know and so yeah reject those
um and uh we were
um
we were lucky enough to have enough work
I mean the question is if we were
desperate for work would we have made
well I I remember that when there was
downturns you would take work you
wouldn't take when things were really
good because you got to feed people sure
sure we we were lucky my mentor a guy
named Bob McCann who said when I started
the company that um you know be careful
because
um design firms tend to porp us meaning
they have too much work and then they
have to go back and forth uh but we were
lucky enough to to
um have you know be the design firm of
record for Apple at the time and so we
just had so much work that we could be
um picky about what else we did and you
in the beginning you were a pure
mechanical Design shop with a little
industrial design right that's what not
because I remember looking at the at the
percentage of people when we first
started studying you it was something
like 37 mechanical engineers and eight
industrial designs yeah well like that
it depends what you call them a
mechanical engineer because our
mechanical engine years came out of the
Stanford design program so they probably
had mechanical engineering degrees but I
wouldn't characterize them as mechanical
engineering and that's you brought a
bill mahogridge and that's what happened
so his firm was primarily industrial
design and we were primarily mechanical
engineering or engineering and so
um uh we started doing projects together
because the client wanted everything
done all the way they wanted both how it
works and how it looks and so that they
didn't have to fight that out we fought
it out and we just um we just started to
realize that we was like it was like an
idea to be full service we could offer
industrial design and Engineering at the
same time
people so tell folks what bill modridge
is famous for I mean he invented the the
modern design for the clamshell laptop
yeah bill bill was a wonderful person I
still miss him every day anyway he um
his firm designed all kinds in in those
days we were designing all kinds I mean
all of us were designing new to the
world stuff because the technology was
just coming up so so I mean I don't know
who what the form of it would have been
but it was easy to do something new to
the world when there wasn't any laptops
there wasn't a mouse so there wasn't you
know pull down menus or whatever so we
were it was pretty heady days as far as
inventing and so Bill uh I was working
for a company called grid systems and
they had they had the first lap grid
wanted to design the first laptop and
bill and his firm designed it it's a
beautiful oh is that the grid was it was
like a five thousand dollar laptop that
yeah that was so expensive nobody would
buy it but but you and those that you
could get the patent for having the the
keys and the display cover each other to
protect each other because they thought
of it well there wasn't any reason to
think about it because there wasn't any
laptops yeah and so so folks look up
Bill's picture he talked and looked like
Obi-Wan Kenobi and Star Wars and he was
so classy I mean that guy was such a
classic I learned a lot from him
absolutely so so idea okay in an idea
we'll get to the d-school in a minute
but the thing about idea was there was
this point where you kind of started
pivoting from uh applying design well to
products to processes into
organizational design I mean I I even
remember uh Diego Rodriguez who I think
is watching that one one of your
partners saying he worked for steel case
when he was young and designed a table
and then he was helping them design
their organizational structure and use
the exact same process yes I think so
talk a little bit about that transition
yeah so
yeah so our process is really uh we call
it human centered but it's really around
trying to understand what's meaningful
to people and how to get things to work
well in the people sense uh and
sometimes that's a product in the
beginning it was only product so that's
all we knew but then it started to move
towards Services right you can see how
the same process of really understanding
um what the tray should look like on an
airplane and how you should serve the
food is very much in the same
understanding what's going on with the
people in this industry right and then
we started designing experiences and
systems and we found that our process
because it was so human centered
for sure but also because it was so
prototype driven that we could quickly
make something and it could be it could
be a story of a service or acting out an
experience right and um you could just
all the the things that were wrong just
came out in the Prototype and then we
just fixed them you know you you you
find you you you you have in your mind
that some something's going to happen a
certain way or something's going to look
or work a certain way and then you build
a quick one and you say oh my God that
you can't walk on that side of that
because you'll bump into this right and
then we can we then we can quickly
change it and so the the our process
seemed to have
um
um seemed to apply broadly both because
of how human-centered it was and and how
quickly we were willing to switch
directions pivot in a different
direction based on on our prototyping so
so I I'm going to tell a little story
and David knows this is coming so with
one of the most amazing things I ever
saw you do and you I saw you do a lot of
amazing things but there used to be at
Ideo this astounding meeting called the
Monday morning meeting and uh and the
best still the best meetings I've ever
been to there'd be 60 people sitting
around and you would have 60 people like
rocking and cranked up at uh nine
o'clock in the morning on and these are
like you know Engineers who like to stay
up late but anyhow so so what David did
is David did this reorganization and
what happened idea got big enough that
you couldn't just have one big group
yeah so you broke it into three Studios
and by the way the most amazing
reorganization I've ever seen those of
you who are watching so probably been
through organizations where you are told
you are reorganized and you are not on
this team well this reorganization was
he had three Studio leaders it was a
Brennan Boyle who were the uh I'm trying
to remember who they and two others and
they made the pitch please join my
studio so people had a choice of what
group they're being put into you go in
any Studio you wanted and people were
really nervous about the reorganization
what David did to see the see his
mustache he shaved off his mustache
nobody had ever seen him without his
mustache and he and he had this line
which I and he said so this organization
it's just like our products this is a
prototype it's just like my mustache I
can grow it back it was and everybody
was just blown away by that in that
reorganization it worked for a while and
then you did something else yeah yeah
but the thing that I loved about that it
it and I still think about that is this
notion that an organization just like a
product is a prototype and that's that's
what we do at the Disco too yeah so yeah
I know the the thing about
organizational changes I mean it needs
to be done even in in almost all
organizations that's why you have a job
anyways but um but it but we always
wanted to be able to say nope that
didn't work you know you know like a
month or two months in
um we one of the we you could say you
could change that we were gonna in the
studios and we say oh no that's not
going to work so we're going to have to
break into these this kind of
organization but um one of the times in
our life we did a lot of work for
Steelcase and one of the big times in
our life was this thing of um moving
from private offices to cubicles which
is a big deal it's a big deal right
still a big deal or or maybe not
cubicles was not a good choice but
um open plan versus private offices
right and we're now almost all open plan
everybody in the planet is almost open
place there's a lot of evidence it just
sucks too by the way but anyway but it
is what it is but
um there at this time you know take a
law firm everybody was in their own
right and we had to try to talk them out
of their offices right and into an open
plan was a really tough sell so just
like everything else we do we would say
um we're gonna try it and if it doesn't
work we're going to go back to the old
way
and in this particular case most people
preferred the open plan with some
enclaves so they could have privacy if
they wanted but in the there was more
exciting to be out in there yeah so so
the I'm thinking of that original
concept was cave and Commons right yes
that's right
because we used to go out and talk with
with Hackett it was the CEO of uh of
Steelcase at the time in in the and I
think the problem with a lot of the
folks who went to open offices is they
give you all Commons and no caves yeah
so so that might be it so so okay the
ideal Adventure interesting fascinating
but and the other thing about David is
and I don't even know how you get away
with this but he's like a full professor
at Stanford he he's got a chair he's in
the National Academy of engineering and
he's a CEO of a company so he's kind of
doing all the stuff and and uh but then
you you get this idea so it's like 2002
and I remember it used to say I want to
start something that's called the
d-school and we'd go to Ideo as it was
like Terry Winograd Bernie Roth Jim
Patel and he'd kind of give us wine and
was in food it was really fun the thing
about David I think I've eaten a hundred
thousand dollars worth of Ideal food in
my life he's I do is very good with food
and and
I just and I I just look at my even my
email folders have Kelly's dream and
then one day you came back with 35
million dollars from hasso Platinum so
we had to do something so why don't you
describe a little bit about yourself
I'm going to go back and talk about
having two full-time jobs I I highly
recommend having two full-time jobs
because in those days when I was not at
ID though they thought I was at Stanford
and when I was not at Stanford they
thought I was audio I could be anywhere
you know I mean I was I could be you
know out in the bay
um so anyway so I really like two
full-time jobs as uh because nobody
knows Dodge
at the B school so the D school
um
uh well first it was a joke the d-school
because the B School such a big deal
here and so we wanted to be funny and so
we caught ourselves to D school we kept
getting ceason's assist
um yeah every administrator told you to
stop calling at the Disco except by the
end they were calling it The D score but
anyway
um
the notion really came to me was that um
if you go around Stanford there's just a
lot of people
in doing something they don't want to do
the you know the professors are teaching
classes they don't want to teach but
they have to teach a certain number of
classes so they teach you know
introduction to chemistry or whatever
they have to teach
and the students really don't want to
take the classes they're they're a lot
of them anyways because they're required
right I mean they would take elective
classes they don't so if you just look
down from the top you see a place where
there's rooms full of people who don't
want to be in those rooms and that made
me think I want a place where
um
where people opt in they're there
because they want to and so initially we
didn't give the students credit for the
classes and we didn't pay the professors
so I remember not being paid today and I
remember you complaining about yeah of
course I complained uh but uh anyway but
so that that option I still taught the
classes though yeah I know you did you
did you did taught a lot of classes and
so that notion of opting in and and
wanting to be there for the right
reasons was the thing that really got me
uh excited and then that you know we we
had done a lot of talking about
multi-disciplinary teaching and stuff
but it really was you know we go to a
meeting and divide up whatever the money
was and go back and do what we were
doing here before and it was so it was
just talk and I really wanted a place
where professors came from all over the
university uh to to teach together and
we were successful at that it was
amazing you know I don't know I think
there's 50 professors teach there oh
it's it's just every Department you know
that so I'm thinking of some of the
because David because this was before
any classes you sort of laid out okay so
classes are required none of our classes
will be required there was that then you
have this concept of sage on stage which
means one Professor like me just talking
the whole time yeah and then no your
thing was the professor doesn't talk so
much the students actually have to do
something and well and and there has to
be multiple professors in the room at
the same time not one point of view at
least two and maybe more and and by the
way just having you know had a taught at
the d-school and having to struggle with
Stanford so at Stanford they try to give
you less credit when you do a team Todd
class even though it's actually more
work because you have to coordinate with
more people yeah so so there's that but
but the other thing and I think this is
getting to prototyping maybe we can talk
about this and and talk about some of
the things that you're most proud of
because the D school really does have
classes where people prototype products
prototype companies they prototype their
lives right I mean it's it's just
remarkable so yeah so talk a little bit
about some of the things that you're
most proud of and it's just right across
from here it's just such a buzzy
exciting place still when I walk in
there I'm like wow
well you know it it's a lot
um it's a lot uh more exciting than I
ever dreamed it would be and it's been
copying you know continuously in
Academia now and that feels that feels
really good but um
what the the things that
um
um remind me there's a class called um
extreme affordability yeah and that was
like the first class did you co-founded
that with Jim Patel yeah and
um
and just seeing how excited the students
were to actually go in country and
prototype something that was going to
help people who had real needs so the
concept of this class is you before the
class it's a two quarter class you send
the students to do need finding all over
the world right well to whatever their
they you know they're going to do you
know uh incubators for babies that in in
India or Africa that don't can't
maintain their body weight in you know
out in the Villages and so they're going
to go to those places yes and do the
need finding there and they're just so
excited when the students come back and
you know and a lot of companies been a
lot of companies that have been started
out of just that class in the in the um
yeah Embrace you're talking about the
one with the baby warmer so yeah so tell
the Embrace story because the Embrace
story is a great story well Embrace
um the students I'll tell a couple quick
ones the students when and uh were kind
of came to the collusion that they
needed more incubators that was because
there were so many babies that died
because they didn't they did they
couldn't keep warm enough to maintain
their body weight and so they went over
to I think design a a low-cost incubator
and then just because of the way the
process our process works they figured
out that didn't didn't do any good have
an incubator in the hospital the people
the babies were all dying out in the
Villages so the problem wasn't to build
a better incubator the problem is to
keep babies warm exactly so they ended
up with making something that looked
like a sleeping bag with paraffin in it
and you heat it up and I don't know how
many hundred thousand lives they've
saved at this point uh but it was it was
that way another one that um is when um
to um
I'm blanking on the name of Terry
winograd's class but
um anyway they they went to Africa to
look at
um
at uh fires they they found that um
they found that you know there were
these Villages were you know the kind of
electrical systems weren't that robust
and so they'd have fires and they went
and I think everybody thought they were
going to do a low-cost fire extinguisher
right
but when they got there and and really
got to know the people they weren't they
were worried about fire but they were
worried about fire for a specific reason
which was their immigration documents
would burn and then they wouldn't be
legal in that place and that was really
scary to them so a fire meant they could
lose their home so
anyways I'll make a long story short the
students figure out that that's really
the problem they get pickup trucks and
get scanners and they go and they go
around and scan all the documents of of
that the people having they put them in
the cloud and now you know you don't
have to worry about your your because
they can pull them they teach them how
to pull them down they don't have to
worry about
um you know the documents burning it's
that kind of excitement you can see how
that would turn Stanford students on to
make that kind of contribution and
there's many many more
and and to me I mean let's maybe just
sort of back up here and we've already
got one questions please keep um asking
questions
um but let's kind of go through because
one of the things that's happened with a
lot of people picking up design thinking
we were talking about this and getting
ready for this that that it's all these
messy things yes but there's two or
three things that you keep coming back
to need finding rapid prototyping what
else what would be a bias towards action
rather than sitting with your laptop in
a room someplace get out there into
things and then humans human centered
yeah so the the bias towards action is
really interesting and I already
mentioned Diego Rodriguez one of your
students
um who we've both learned a lot from and
and this is question I've taught with
Diego at the d-school and people say
bias towards actions you're going to
screw things up but but Diego always
asks this question I love which is where
is your place for failing so it's sort
of like the difference between crashing
in the flight simulator versus the
actual airplane yeah so how do you how
do you get because and you've worked
with a lot of organizations that are
really resistant to trying anything oh
it might screw it up right so how do you
how do you get them to sort of move
yeah well um because you're very
Charming with this no well you I don't
know about that but um it um what we
believe is that you need to
um do something that uh Albert bandura
called the guided Mastery a series of
small successes you can't go into um
to a to a company and do the kind of
wholesale change that we would have in
mind when we first got there right
because they would just it would be
rejected right too different right and
so
um
the trick is to to have some like
experiments have some little
um winds by picking something that's
smaller and and there's an and there's
obvious we want to set it us up for
Success so there's obviously a pivot
from where the people are thinking they
should go what they're doing now and if
you just pivot a little bit you get a
much better result and so we start by
um start by having those little wins and
then people start to notice and oh I
wanted I want to have you know I want to
do things that way if that's going to be
successful so it's uh it takes a lot of
of um small wins so I mean a good
example of that and I'd love with you um
to jump in on this I mean one of idio's
biggest clients while was uh Procter and
Gamble yes this amazing woman Claudia
Katra who we just love Claudia so
Claudia LED this design thinking
movement and it spread throughout much
of the company and had a big effect but
I remember she started with the Mr Clean
people because
first of all they were desperate because
they were Mr Clean was just sort of like
sales were just going down and down and
and and they were so desperate that you
worked with them to help reform and you
came up with the Swiffer right well I'm
not sure you're I was not on that
project but something yes something
um that was new to the world came out of
the the dull thing that that they had
right right and so yeah that's that I
mean that's not a tip atypical for Ideo
or for the d-square you know you can you
you uh you can go and it's part of it is
you know the leadership being so open at
both places I mean
um Sarah Stein Greenberg who's the
executive director of the d-school is
really really good at um getting people
to do stuff that needs to be done and
and that they um they feel like they
contribute uh uh across the board and so
her team is uh is is doing a fantastic
job right now
I just walked across there from there
all right okay so we got some question
um okay so this is Ajit I don't know
where Ajit just sometimes companies have
a hard time getting buy-in from clients
around design thinking even Centric
process it feels strange and wrong to
them so how do you get them on board you
just talked about doing a little small
win yeah um I I remember hasso platner
our donor the hustle platner Institute
of Design once I I have one answer and
I'll see what it so I I remember I was
at sap giving a talk and and Hasa was
giving grief uh I won't name him but but
to another executive and he said to the
executive this is a guy who led strategy
I don't understand a word you say I
understand every word that David Kelly
says so that's one thing you say is you
actually speak English
so that's one way to convince him what
what else do you do to get buy-in
um well I think um it's about
storytelling to get buy-in you got to be
good at storytelling right and um I
think in most cases especially when the
product or service has social value
which is the kind of stuff we tend to
work on now
um a well done video that builds empathy
for the people if you can picture if
you're the company and you're having
trouble buying into the process
um if you can show a few
um
uh empathy based videos of what's going
to happen if we do it this way
um it's you that's the human part it
eventually wins people over I mean yes
the company you know is worried about
shareholder value more than they're
worried about taking care of everybody
but I you know it's a it's a it's a
getting good at storytelling and make
quick little videos painting a picture
of the future I mean the hard part is
when they're when they're having trouble
um accepting this process
um they're not thinking about what the
consequence is to the Future because
nobody's shown that if you can paint a
picture of what the future is going to
be like with these new ideas in it
somehow that's easy for people to it's
like you see science fit if you read a
science fiction book it's easy to
picture what would happen if that I mean
so one thing that sort of comes to mind
to be a little concrete so in the early
days and I used to think you were nuts
by the way there's a lot of times I
thought you were crazy yeah he had this
picture in front of his office he had
this picture of where's Waldo yeah and
and you had people sort of running
around in different groups and that was
your vision of the d-school and that's
kind of how the diesel works yeah if you
stand up on the second floor and look
down in a day when like when it's easy
when it's busy it looks like it's just
like where's Waldo so so what do I know
because you have these pictures um so
this idea is sort of painting a picture
future and then getting people to live
little pieces of it that's one of the
sort of experience yes prototypes that
you guys are really good at building
students are really good at it but I I
just even remember uh to tell tales on
uh one of your great students Perry
Claymont is one of the best teachers at
the Stanford D School Perry was well he
invented the modern Snowshoe he was very
senior at Patagonia and now teaches all
sorts of classes so Perry was the CEO of
Timbuktu he was CEO of Timbuktu and our
students we took him up on a bus and
Perry's CEO he had the worst corporate
meeting I have ever seen in my life and
literally our students were on the bus
we couldn't believe people were falling
asleep they were interrupting they were
confused I mean it was really like
terrible and blessed Perry's heart what
we did was we had our students come in
and what they did was they had him and
his team role play what a good meeting
would be and and so that was to me
that's sort of living the future and he
did change the meeting yeah um and and
you are very good at running meetings
well Perry is probably good too but that
was to me a really good example of our
students created an experienced
prototype in the d-school we put it on
the bus we go to the meeting we observe
it and then we build the Prototype and
then we try to get the user uh to
critique it and then to live it and try
it in the in the real world maybe that's
the full cycle design
there are there are better I mean
there's you know I mean there's science
here you know that's what you I mean
there there are better ways to run
meetings and worse ways around meetings
there are better ways to incentivize
employees and worse ways to incentivize
in place so you know if if you can get
it right then you know the question is
of getting them to adopt it if you can
get it right and show some small
successes people move they know they
don't move a 100 no no no they move a
bit and then once once we're going and
and there's a couple of successful uh
products or Services out there then it
really
um it really can take off because people
want to be successful and they see it a
new way to be successful they do that
and that's why people like you're
talking about Claudia kochka that's why
she
um protected people in a in a most
people uh today have some kind of design
d-school-like place inside of the
company it was called the gym I think
near the gym that's right I remember the
gym yeah anyways well that's to protect
them long enough to have some success
right right so and you know one of the
things to be snide but one of the things
that I used to hear I'm your designers
say is you don't show unfinished work to
stupid people so so there's there's some
people you can sort of show your really
crappy prototype too right I actually I
even remember uh bill mogridge I won't
name the company but like yelling not
very nicely at somebody who had spent
like a hundred thousand dollars on this
prototype he said that's the Prototype
you should have made with paper for 10
bucks yeah
um but but this idea of not showing um
unfinished work and making it safe for
the idea it's actually it's funny it's
funny you bring that up I actually met I
I kind of measure companies Now by how
crummy the Prototype is that they can
take to the CEO if the C if the CEO is
hitting on all cylinders with respect to
this then they're happy to see
unfinished work right a crummy prototype
but that's not the way most companies
are if you've got 10 minutes with the
CEO you polish you make it perfect you
make it perfect you know but you're not
at that point so now you're at the whim
of whether she or he
um like it whereas if instead if he'd
gone in you know two months earlier and
said boss this is what I'm thinking
there's these three what do you think
yeah then you would have yeah but I'm
sorry no no but the CEOs are are usually
so busy and everything that they're not
um they're not
um happy about going seeing the crummy
stuff right right right and are you
talking about Jim hacker to a CEO of
Steelcase Anna Ford I think Jim is
somebody you can show pretty crummy in
fact I remember he wants to he wants to
have his say he wants to have you know
uh and his point of view Incorporated
down the road well I remember I think
you got Hackett hooked on Ideo he was
head of marketing at Steelcase before a
CEO and he was on a team and he was
there prototyping at midnight with him
like cutting up boxes I mean you you
really got him to drink the drink the
the Kool-Aid so um
so I mean this idea of prototyping is
interesting so so there's some questions
here and I I I like I like this question
from May about uh there's a couple
questions here about being design
thinking being a buzzword and so forth
and the interesting thing and just the
the years I've known you nobody knew
what design thinking was in fact when I
first met you nobody used the word
design thinking and then and people used
to joke maybe it's called design doing
instead of design thinking and stuff
like that and there was there's been
this sort of Arc and we talked and this
happens to almost all management
movements where first it's an idea
nobody knows what it is and I even
remember Claudia kochka who was one of
the early adopters saying I'm not going
to call it design thinking because
nobody what it is I'm just going to call
it Innovation and then all these people
adopted it yeah and now we have a
situation
where let's be honest in some places
it's not getting a great name because
it's not being done very well that's
right so why don't you talk a little bit
about the Arc of the movement well I
think I think I mean I'm not in
embarrassed by that I think all
movements do that quality movement same
story so we just had there was just a
big fight about design thinking on our
alumni thing and um so it's it's the
part about not doing it well so if you
go up and you just you kind of slap the
word design thinking on whatever process
you have then you can say boy that
doesn't work very well right right we
know I mean I'm going to be arrogant but
we know works I mean you know we've seen
it happen so maybe it doesn't work yeah
it works a lot of places but um but now
you've got now as it gets to be um uh
watered down let's say then yeah no I
mean we see people saying they do design
thinking they're not even talking to
customers you know they're doing the sit
in their office with the laptop open
they're kind of design thinking the same
thing happened with the first thing that
happened in that in my life was
brainstorming so brainstorming yeah
I remember and it was very useful in
generating lots of ideas
um but as it caught on it began to mean
a meeting
any meeting where you were going to talk
about uh you know ideas was the brain so
oh let's have a brainstormer well
brainstormer has a formal rules and a
exact you know layout on how you do it
and uh and it became mean a meeting well
design thinking is in that well so the I
mean brainstorming is an interesting
example because I mean idea was famous
for brainstorming you had a famous ABC
Nightline the best-selling Nightline
video of all times with was when you
made the shopping cart yeah and there
was all this brainstorming session it
looked really cool and brainstorming was
important at least when we studied Ideo
but one thing that Andy hargiton and I
figured out is people spent less than
five percent of their time in
brainstorms yeah they it was part of a
whole process so people would say oh
brainstorming doesn't work and to us
brainstorming is just one little part of
the creative process you got to have the
Prototype you got to test it you got to
revise it yeah and and maybe you'd have
a special brainstorm if you were stuck
with a design problem where people would
come in and try to fix it yeah I I
remember going to a brainstorm is a
specific technical problem and people
fixed it and then we ended the
brainstorm after about 20 minutes yeah
so at some point we get to people you
know like I never use the word
brainstorm anymore I probably won't use
the word design thinking right anymore
right it's just it's just uh how it
happens
um and but you know people are really
good at um latching on to some kind of
uh frame right right and and so in the
early days the design thinking was a
really good frame to say I'm going to
act differently right really so I'm it's
and the company is going to allow me to
act differently and that in itself and
then it makes a difference about the
process but that in itself you know I'm
allowed and see people say that all the
time about the d-school uh professors
from different parts of the University
they say boy I walk across the threshold
and I know I'm allowed to active really
here so so I mean just one test that I
use and let's go look at some of the
other questions here but one test that I
use
because a lot of the organizations we
work with because we do uh teaching at
the D school so they'll set up a
teaching operation where they teach uh
sort of watered down 45-minute versions
of design thinking and they'll say we've
trained one company in particular that
was a decently yeah yeah I'm not going
to name them they they were really proud
of training something like 5 000 people
right and then so I kept asking the
question and I asked this question for
years can I can you show me one product
or service that has been changed by
Design thinking and they'd always change
the subject and eventually after a
decade they have abandoned their design
thinking movement and what that meant
was they ended the classes but they they
never implemented the process in
everyday life and that's what Claudia
kochka did was actually there was some
classes but she would find specific
products and services that in
organizational designs that needed to be
changed at Procter Gamble and her people
would change them and to me that's a
there's a difference between talking
about it and doing it and I think
training is really uh dangerous yes it
is I I do think that um sometimes these
movements I'm not thinking about design
thinking in general but sometimes these
movements serve their purpose because
they allow people to have a new frame
and that so I when the one just thought
of it was hack it at Ford had this thing
called now near far now near far now and
so whenever you were talking about a
product where you had to talk about
what's the now version of that what's
the near coming and what's the far
version of that and it it sounds like a
pretty simple thing but it really made
everybody have a different discussion
rather than like work on one thing and
work on a new car no they worked on the
near your car you know the now car the
near car and the far car and so it
really set you I mean I'm just saying
it's just a random example of how having
a frame and I think design thinking was
a frame for some people and had some
Advantage even if they didn't uh use it
properly
okay properly defined by us which isn't
it doesn't mean it's proper okay so
there's a couple questions here which
I'll get to but one thing I kind of want
to do we got about what 18 minutes left
is so one thing that's amazing about
knowing David the years I have is is
that the number of people famous people
who have like just been sort of uh
smitten with you I've seen and one let's
kind of go through and talk about what
you've learned about chip fixing a word
you don't like we can talk about how you
would fix the word [ __ ] pictures I have
to tell a story so when we had a news
Provost here persist drought yes and I
was at the Disco and Tom Hanks happened
to be there and she said to me this is
this a normal day give me a tour because
one of his kids was there so yeah his
kid was here but you being with Tom
Hanks is not as all shopping shopping so
so well we'll start with Tom Hanks so
what'd you learn from Tom Hanks
um I learned and that you can be you
know that all that Hollywood Glitz and
stuff you can be a completely different
kind of person you can be a you know a
really solid citizen who cares about
things that are important like
typewriters and in fact he's obsessed
with typewriters is a whole documentary
about his typewriters but I mean he's a
really good actor but he is having
dinner with him he is uh just a a a a a
genuinely nice person but I don't know
how we got off on him well well so let's
talk I mean Steve Jobs who you he was
one of your best friends you were very
close to to Steve Jobs so so tell us a
little bit about what you learned from
Steve Jobs and maybe what you taught him
too because he you have a pattern with
him even on the Apple three I remember
that yeah yeah you know I don't know if
I taught him anything but he taught me a
lot I mean any design firm any designer
who worked for Steve he was their best
client they they would tell you for sure
because he cared so much right and so
what I learned from him was you should
do everything to the hilt I mean you
know why why not care about the box that
it's in you know why why you know and
and so um it was it was great because
you could just you know go
you know just go to the to the most
extreme thing you could think of and he
would entertain it right even though he
would sometimes say well it's too
expensive but he would still challenge
you to go back so some days some days
you were a hero and that felt really
good and some days you were a heel
because he would say that's not good
enough or I thought you were good or
what something something tough he's
tough but um but it always in was in the
the
process of trying to make something like
really much better than you thought you
could make and you know so
you know I mean the the most famous
thing we did from was the mouse and
um he he wanted it for I don't know
Seventeen dollars or so it was some
number like that the team could tell you
anyway and um we were not coming
anywhere close to that
and so expensive too expensive and so we
um
we just kept kept at it and the thing
happened there which is really
interesting was we were trying to make
the mouse such that it was accurate
meaning you moved the mouse on the table
an inch and then it moved on the screen
1.00 inches right and so that was that
Precision was adding a lot of cost into
the mouse and then one time when we were
fooling around with it we realized the
human brains in the loop if you draw the
block diagram we don't need to be that
accurate you got the human brain right
right in Loop so if you want to move it
from here to to this point the person's
brain stops it it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter so now
the cost just went and I think that's
the kind of thing that Steve would force
you to do in order to make his
unrealistic goals so I mean he I mean he
was a complicated character one person
I've talked about him a lot with not as
much as you
um is Ed catmore from Pixar worked with
him for 28 eight years yeah and and the
one thing Ed would say is that yes he
would get mad sometimes but but the main
thing he would do with Pixar is he would
push people for Pride yeah that you want
to be proud of the work that you did
when you look well if you please Steve
you were proud I mean that's that was
for sure I remember actually because
I've been around Ideo so long I remember
I was hanging around idea when he came
back Steve came back in 1997 as as an
interim CEO to fix the company one of
the first things he did was he called
Denny Boyle yeah uh just retired from
Ideo recently who was it he was one of
your first eight employees or so wasn't
he and and Danny I think designed 40
Apple products and one of the things
that Steve did because he'd been gone
for a while was he called Denny and said
run me through the the Apple product
line and tell me what you think of it so
that was the sort of relationship that
you had with them yeah yes it did yeah
and you know I mean he we all hear all
these um you hear all these uh
stories about how tough he was and he
was tough and he was difficult to work
with but he's also very
um caring person you know he had cancer
and I had cancer and when I uh when he
found out that I had cancer he came over
the house and he came over the house
regularly and um you know helped me
through you know making decisions about
chemotherapy and stuff like that and he
gives it you in the hospital and and he
did and he he nag your doctors and
nurses to take care of you I mean such a
complicated guy both loving and
difficult all at the same yeah my my
surgeon I mean who you know for years I
I went back to um you know to have to
have him look at my throat again and my
surgeon always retold me the story of
jobs coming in his office and and poking
him on the chest and told him he was
going to do a good job of surgery
so he had high standards well good and
you're still alive yeah I'm still alive
so so I mean so that's one of the
stories about Steve is that you hear the
comp he was a very complicated person
and and certainly I wrote a book called
The no hassle Rule and I do mention that
he could be an [ __ ] sometime but a
complicated person yeah um Okay so we've
got about 13 minutes
um uh this one's too found from Barrett
any insights on bring Innovation to the
Department of Motor Vehicles okay you
can fix the California give me an idea
um you know the truth is the department
I mean it's a mess but the Department of
Motor Vehicle holds made a big leap when
they started having appointments right
yeah so there's a line that that's just
as bad as it always was right but
there's a line next to it that if you
you know get an appointment or willing
to wait until the your appointment date
they're pretty efficient I mean I was
surprised I'm a collector of old cars
and so I'm at the DMV a lot because you
know they're always doing different
things and getting license plates from
the year that the car was made and all
that kind of stuff and I think it got a
lot better but
um the main thing is the way the way to
improve it in my mind would be to make
it uh more enjoyable for the people who
work there
is a great place to work we we did a
bank for uh Carlos Rodriguez Pasteur um
in in Peru the richest guy in Peru
basically yeah but that but it was the
same thing with the tellers in the in
the bank how do you make them and we did
this one little thing which we put a
little like white board Blackboard next
to thing and and then they wrote
something on it like
I remember one guy wrote I want to be
the president of Peru right or you know
um I love scuba diving or whatever and
then we watched as the people coming up
to the to the teller had something to
talk to the talent about so humanizes
them and humanize them and it's you know
it that's the that's the DMV needs
DMV needs is you know for that person
not to be you know I I as I say I go
there all the time I just try to be
sickening sweet so that I can get
through my process and agree with them
but um it's because their job is just
not very fulfilling so so I mean one
example following Barrett's thing that I
that I it's not the DMV but it's close
there were three different folks
um who went through the Stanford D
school
um who started a a non-profit in mission
called Sevilla to improve the process I
don't know if you heard about this I
think it's an amazing story and and what
they did was there's a benefits form for
people who get unemployment insurance uh
health care services from the state of
Michigan
um that about two and a half million
people fill out every year and it was
the worst form in the country and they
made it about a third the length
and they made it much more clear they
just this form and they've saved
thousands of hours and also one of the
side effects you talk about the people
who work in the Social Services offices
they worked really heavily with them so
the number of people who go to those
offices because they can't figure out
how to fill out the form even though
more people are filling it out it's
dropped by about 50 percent and to me
that's a you know this that isn't
exactly the DMV but it's pretty close
it's in in people talk about the notion
that um that government services well we
have to have them and they can be better
in fact one of the guests we're going to
have in November here is a guy named
Todd Park who was CTO for Obama and he
some of us will remember all the
problems of signing up for uh Obamacare
the charitable website so he led an
effort to fix that cool so and to me
that's consistent with design thinking
you prototype you'd be user focused yeah
and you get things done yeah one of the
things that's most rewarding in some
ways is when like you when you work with
the group you were just talking about
working with a Social Services Group or
if we worked for the DMV people
um and and we fixed it and it was much
better the just them saying that this
happens a lot with pride saying I'm the
one right yes I'm the one who I mean
just the ownership of the change is also
really important yeah and and and the
story from Sevilla is it is it the
people who they initially stereotype
there's these sort of heartless
bureaucrats they said these people cared
the most they had the most information
these are these people are the reason
that they fixed it and and because they
knew the problems and you know there's
this great uh there's this great Michael
Lewis the guy who wrote liars poker and
all the other stuff he has this notion
uh that that you find the person six
levels down yeah and that's the person
who knows how the system works so well I
certainly don't want to give anybody the
impression that the designers go in and
design stuff for other people the truth
is you know you co-design it with the
people who actually own the problem
right and so the the um the um it's it's
those people who you as a designer I
don't know enough about right the
details of how you know the voting Works
in Los Angeles although we built a new
voting machine for them but there are
people there
and their knowledge and their if you can
turn them on right their knowledge plus
our methodology is what what's happened
well but I I love that so one one of the
principles that I picked up from David
is that when you solve a problem you
want people who know too much yeah and
no almost nothing that combination and
I'm the example I always think of as
Jane Goodall when she studied the Apes
yeah that she was hired uh by Richard
Leakey famous Lewis Leakey actually
famous the father famous Anthropologist
and he wouldn't let her read anything
about chimps he just sent her in the
field that I forgot was going on so she
wouldn't be biased and that that idea of
people who know too much and that's kind
of the heart of design thinking that's
why you have a few old farts and then
you hire a bunch of young people at idio
too yeah well um it there you know
experts are really important in the
process and sometimes when you hear
designers like me talking it sounds like
we're saying we design it we didn't
design it we designed it alongside of
the X experts who actually knew the
stuff who actually knew the detail of
how something works or why something's
important and but I still remember in
fact I think this is how you got steel
case as a client
um was that somebody was saying but
you've never designed like Furniture
before and you made the argument in your
Charming way that the fact that um that
he had nobody who'd ever done it before
you come up with fresh eyes and so you
knew too little and they knew too much
and plus you had the design process yeah
yeah you since we don't I I said since
we don't since we don't know anything
about chairs it's a pretty good chance
that our chair will be different from
other chairs it was
okay we've got about five minutes uh
let's see ooh I I kind of like Kaylee's
question because this is this is a
challenge that both the d-school and I
do how do you work with Executives
without becoming just another product
team that works on the executive's pet
project so how do you get something
that's valuable rather than some man or
woman who's got too much power and is
obsessed with something that's silly
yeah it's um
uh it's a problem and but I
what the real answer the thing is we can
take on the CEO in his pet project if
you're an employee you can't
right right right right so
um so uh especially when the employees
know that this project is not doesn't
make any sense but they have to work on
it so so I think the that we're good at
storytelling and so normally I'd say yes
you could do that which you want but how
about you know 15 degrees off of that
diverted off of that is this and then 30
degrees off of that what you're talking
about was this and then like tell the
story so well of the Alternatives that
um that it's not a meritocracy all the
time right right but a lot of times you
can get somebody enthusiastic when it's
when it still has the DNA of the thing
they wanted to do it's just actually
something worth doing well I mean so one
way I've sort of seen that both at Ideo
in the d-school and in fact the
incubator Project's a great example of
that because whatever the client was was
they thought they wanted an incubator
yeah and in the way that uh the team
shifted it was well the pro it's the
problem that that the person's um
concerned with so the problem in that
case was not a better incubator the
problem is keeping babies warm yeah you
tend to always go up one level higher
right to find what the what the purpose
is or you know what what's really a
value and then you can come back down to
it uh if you start at the at the place
where you needed low-cost incubator you
got a problem right because you don't
need a local incubator and you know some
of the incubators were already empty
anyway so we were in the wrong place
right so it's it you know you can really
change the thing but it's usually you
you pivot to some place that's uh one
level higher than what the person is
saying the problem that's usually an
answer what they're saying is usually an
answer not a problem right and you need
to get up to the what's the problem okay
we've got like two minutes I I can't
resist this one somebody asked this one
so since you've done a lot of this so
how might design thinking processes help
institutions of Higher Learning so how
could you actually get Stanford to
change or birching my own too difficult
a client Stanford
no I mean you know it's like what we do
right you it just takes longer
um you know there's no there's no um
um you know money involved that you can
use as a surrogate for what works and
what doesn't work and if you're at
Stanford you know we try to get we just
tried made a new independent major out
of our old major but it took a lot it
takes longer I mean one thing that I
think that you've taught me and I I
learned from you in a famous
organizational theorist named Jim March
that organizations even large complex
ones change quickly and easily just not
in the direction that any one person
wants and you've made had Stanford
change in a whole bunch of ways that
just amazes me the fact that the
d-school exists I still don't believe it
exists even though it's 50 people
I think that we are it close